le truc c'est que quand je mets objectif
dans les titres des vidéos je me
retrouve généralement avec l'algorithme
youtube
dans la catégorie coach de vie machin
truc et autres conneries là kit propose
de devenir riche beau intelligent alors
que nous on est bien d'accord on parle
d'objectifs d'appareils photo
la du verre un diaf peu d'électronique
voilà tes objectifs quoi fin de trucs
comme ça et on va en parler on va en
parler
juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis ravie comme toujours un de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle vidéo sur
cette chaîne on parle de création vidéo
de montage de caméras d'objectifs comme
on va parler aujourd'hui donc si c'est
des choses qui vous intéresse n'hésitez
pas à cliquer sur le bouton s'abonner
activer la cloche tout ça tout ça me
suivre sur un stade aussi ça peut être
cool s'il ya plein de behind the thin
sur un stade donc n'hésitez pas à faire
tout ça aujourd'hui on va parler de
quelque chose de super important quand
vous tourner une vidéo cvo optique on va
essayer de voir trois optiques qui
coûtent pas vraiment très cher et qui
sont super efficace parce que vous aurez
beau avoir la meilleure caméra du monde
si vous mettez une optique tout pourri
dessus et ben l'image sera pas ouf
et inversement des fois avec une caméra
pas ouf pas hyper récente si on met des
optiques de très bonne qualité dessus on
peut avoir un résultat vraiment vraiment
surprenant moi je suis de ceux qui
essayent de privilégier les optiques
plus que le boîtier un même si les deux
sont importants l'optique c'est vraiment
très très très très très important alors
quelques petites précisions de rigueur
juste avant de parler de ces trois
optiques qui sont à des prix très
abordables je vous parle ici d'optique
pour des boîtiers sony ce que je suis en
train d'utiliser là mais je vais essayer
de généraliser un peu plus à des
catégories d'optique est donnée d
équivalent pour que quel que soit votre
boîtier ben vous trouviez aussi votre
bonheur les optiques dont je vous
parlais cd optique récente avec
autofocus tout ça c'est pas des optiques
vintage qui peuvent être très bien aussi
et là on est plus dans la bricole des
fois avec des bagues etc
là on est vraiment sur des optiques
simple à utiliser et récentes
et pour finir je vous donnerai les prix
neuf de ses optiques et aussi d'occasion
c'est encore moins cher
un même si voilà abordable pas cher tout
est relatif là on est vraiment dans des
choses qui sont pour des optiques de
cette qualité vraiment vraiment
abordable est vraiment pas cher alors
c'est 3 optique là ce sont des focales
fixes par opposition à des zooms ça veut
donc dire qu'on a qu'une plage focale on
peut pas où mais dézoomer c'est pas
possible c'est vraiment une focale et
vous allez me dire mais pourquoi
s'emmerder avec trois optiques il faut
changer et c'est alors quelqu'un je peux
tout faire
ah je vous explique la première raison
c'est que souvent
les focales fixes sont de meilleure
qualité que les zooms on va très souvent
avoir moins de déformation parce qu'il
ya moins d'éléments dans le fût on aura
aussi très souvent un meilleur piqué un
meilleur rendu d'image il ya aussi le
fait que les focales fixes ouvre à prix
égal généralement beaucoup plus grand
que des zooms et je suis pas en train de
dire qu'il faut que filmé en permanence
à f/1 4 1 c'est pas du tout ça l'idée
mais qui peut le plus peut le moins et
puis à titre d'exemple chez sony par
exemple si on veut des zooms comme le 16
35 24 70 le 70 200 qui ouvre grand c'est
à dire le maximum ici cf 2,8 faut
compter 12 millions euros par optique
donc là on est vraiment sur quelque
chose de beaucoup moins cher que ça donc
si vous avez un petit budget optique
mais que vous voulez un maximum de
qualité go focale fixe
ceci étant dit occupons nous de nos
trois optiques et on va aller de la
moins chère à la plus chère la moins
chère étant le 50 mm f/1 8 alors voilà
la bébête c'est une toute petite optique
là si je la fais tomber
pas cool et cette optique c'est une des
moins chères si ce n'est la moins chère
qu on peut trouver chez sony est aussi
chez beaucoup d'autres constructeurs 50
mm pour du plein format c'est les
optiques les plus simples à fabriquer ce
qui explique leur prix on la trouve neuf
entre 200 et 250 euros et en occasions
on peut la trouver entre 100 et 150
euros donc vraiment celle optique la
moins chère qui existe chez sony et chez
d'autres chez cannon je me rappelle
j'avais payé l'équivalent le 50 mm f/1 8
peu près 100 euros d'occasion pour le
prix pourquoi se priver comme je disais
elle ouvre à f 1,8 donc dans des
situations de basses lumières elle va
être vraiment intéressante puisqu'elle
ouvre grande va récupérer plein de
lumière c'est pas l'optique la plus
charte du monde 1 c'est sûr que il ya
des choses beaucoup mieux fichu que
celle ci mais elle al'avantage d'être
tout petit donc sur un boîtier
mirrorless on est vraiment hyper léger
elle pèse rien en plus on est vraiment
hyper compact et on a vendu 50 mm un peu
je dis bien un peu que je dis vraiment
bien un peu cinéma parce que c'est une
focale d'un cinéma qui est souvent
utilisé on peut faire du portrait mais
on a quand même pas mal d'éléments au
tour en fonction de là où on va se
situer on peut mettre du décor donc
vraiment c'est une focale mois que
j'aime beaucoup que j'utilise
régulièrement petit point négatif sur
celle là comme sûre la cannon
l'autofocus à tendance a pompé pas mal
et être à ces bruits on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de low cost mais avec une
qualité optique qui pour le prix défient
toute concurrence
d'ailleurs j'avais fait une petite vidéo
comparative que je vous mets là qui
s'affiche entre une optique 50 km signer
et cette petite optique sony f18 non
vraiment pour le prix je franchement ça
fait une optique en plus c'est une
focale fixe elle est vraiment pas mal
foncez si vous l'avez pas la deuxième
optique que j'aime énormément c'est la
sigma art 16 mm f/1 4 vraiment je
l'adoré celle là est vraiment vraiment
très très cool alors cette optique là
c'est une optique pour apc un pas pour
plein format donc pour rappel les
capteurs aps et ce sont des capteurs
plus petit que les plein format mais ici
elle exploite une capacité camon alpha 7
3 qui est vraiment sympa c'est la
capacité super 35 c'est à dire que la 7
3 on va faire un crop directement dans
son capteur pour pouvoir utiliser des
optiques aps c parce que normalement si
on met une optique aps c sur un capteur
plein format on a dû vignetage ça va pas
prendre tout le capteur donc la c3 fait
automatiquement un crop dans l'image dès
qu'on lui montre une optique aps c sans
perte de résolution un nom reste en 4k
si on filme en 4k ou en full hd
c'est pas un zoom c'est vraiment il
utilise juste une partie de son capteur
donc cette série
sigma art déjà toute la série est
vraiment vraiment très très sympa donc
dès que vous voyez
sigma art sur des optiques vous pouvez
vous dire que c'est de la bonne qualité
de très belles images qu'on va pouvoir
sortir avec même si on est on appelle
ces et celle ci donc c'est un sage mm
c'est un équivalent 24 mm pour les plein
forme c'est à dire que voilà vous
attendez pas à voir un ultra grand-angle
ça reste un grand angle mais on sera
plus proche des 24 mm du rendu des 24 mm
que des 16 mm sachant qu'elle ouvre à
1,4 donc elle aussi en faible luminosité
elle aura pas de souci et moi ce que
j'adore faire c'est la montée sur le
petit à 6400 que j'ai sur le rhône a
assez pour faire des plans larges des
plans d'installation des des plans
d'architecturé des plans pour situer les
lieux ou tout simplement suivre un sujet
c'est vraiment une optique qui est super
bien pour ça même en photo elle se
démerde bien
elles coûtent entre 350 et 400 euros
neuve mais on peut la trouver entre 250
et 300 euros d'occasion
c'est une optique est assez courante
qu'on trouve régulièrement sur le bon
coin ça existe pour monture canon ça
existe aussi pour monture micro 4/3 donc
vraiment là dessus vous pouvez y aller
aussi les yeux fermés c'est une très
bonne optique pour tout ce qui est un
petit peu large et je vous mets un lien
ici vert à la chaîne du copain victor
qui a fait une vidéo spécialement sur
cette optique qui est vraiment très
sympa ils rendent beaucoup plus dans le
détail donc aller faire un tour sur la
chaîne de victoire si vous voulez en
savoir un petit peu plus sur cette
optique là enfin la dernière optique
dont on va parler aujourd'hui c'est
celle ci le 85 mm sony f-18 et j'aime
bien parce que là on dirait que je parle
à l'envers et c'est très rigolo et ça
vous permet de voir aussi à quel point
elle ouvre grand cette optique pas vu
c'est quand même assez gaillard effet un
mythe en termes d'ouverture cette
optique là c'est un petit peu l'opposé
de la sigma c'est à dire que celle ci
c'est d'une optique qui orientaient
plutôt portrait 85 mm c'est une focale
assez longue
donc on va s'en servir la plupart du
temps pour avoir des gros plans pour
avoir des choses un petit peu plus serré
tout comme la 50 mm elle ouvre à f 1,8
donc aucun problème en basse lumière
pour avoir aussi un beau flou
d'arrière-plan bien entendu puisque plus
on est ouvert grand un plus on a des
faits bockel avantages qu'elles à celle
ci c'est que comme on est sur une focale
longue
on a beaucoup plus de compression de
l'arrière-plan on va avoir une sensation
de plus de beau qui on aura besoin d'eux
peut-être aussi d'ouvrir un petit peu
moins grand pour avoir ce flou
d'arrière-plan et on va réussir à
obtenir un sujet bien détaché de
l'arrière-plan beaucoup plus facilement
qu'avec le 16 mm par exemple même s'il
ouvre à f 1,4 ici on à la compression
qui va beaucoup jouer qui va donner un
rendu très très très sympa puis celle
optique que moi j'habite japy lé tri
optique que j'habite tué l'optique que
j'appelle ces l'optique que moi
j'appelle la machine à birol elle est
compacte mais permet quand même d'avoir
des gros plans sans avoir besoin d'être
hyper près de son sujet c'est pas très
lourd là encore on est un petit peu
comme sur le 50 mm par comparaison voilà
allez un petit peu plus grosse que le 50
mm mais ça reste quand même hyper
contact cette optique elle coûte 9 entre
5 et 600 euros ce qui est un petit peu
plus cher que les optiques dont on a
parlé avant en occasions on la trouve
assez facilement aux alentours des 4 100
euros vous retrouvez aussi des
équivalents 56 mm / ap sc ou 40 mm
micro 4/3 à peu près on arrive après une
rendu similaire il ya une autre marque
qui s'appelle ville trucks qui fabrique
un équivalent à cette optique lavedan
les 350 euros alors j'ai pas testé mais
des tests que j'ai vu sur sur internet
ça avait l'air plutôt pas mal rapport
qualité prix vraiment intéressant donc
si vraiment vous voulez vous orienter là
dessus que vous avez pas le budget
peut-être essayer la ville trucks je les
ai pas testé allez faire un tour sur
internet pour vous faire votre avis mais
en tout cas celle ci est vraiment cool
allez petit plus par rapport aux deux
autres celle ci elle a un bouton ici
pour passer de focus manuel à focus
automatique et un bouton ici qu'on peut
personnaliser pour va donner une
fonction supplémentaire on peut assigner
en fait des fonctions du boîtier sur ce
bouton là sur les deux autres y a rien à
ce niveau là pas de boutons
personnalisables ni de switch pour
passer de focus manuel à focus
automatique
et voilà les amis je pense que déjà avec
ses 3 optique là vous pouvez faire plein
plein plein de choses vous allez pas
avoir la marge de manoeuvre qu'on peut
avoir sur un zoom mais vous aurez le
meilleur de la qualité je pense à un
prix vraiment très très abordable avec
ce combo déjà je pense que ça couvre on
va dire 80% des besoins qu'on peut avoir
en vidéo manquerez peut-être un petit 35
mm par exemple chez samian que je sais
quelque chose qui se font qu'ils sont
plutôt pas mal en 35 mm et qui sont
assez abordable aussi mais voilà on a
fait le tour de quand même trois
optiques très sympa et puis si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me
mettre le traditionnel coup de blaster
sur le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste
en dessous de cette vidéo qui s'est pas
déjà fait n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
on est de plus en plus nombreux c'est
bien assez ou sur cette chaîne et puis
bien entendu il faut cliquer sur la
cloche 1 pour être notifiée de quand je
sors une nouvelle vidéo
j'arrive à me tenir à une par semaine en
ce moment c'est être pas durer mais
voilà donc profité à et puis dans les
commentaires n'hésitez pas à partager
vos bons plans sur les optiques s'il y
en a d'autres que vous utilisez qui sont
abordables mais tout ça dans les
commentaires et puis partager avec le
reste de la communauté c'est super cool
partager c'est bien on est là pour ça
pour ça prend des choses et puis pour
s'aider les uns les autres et voilà le
but de cette chaîne c'est ça et puis les
amis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux rester très curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine
oui je peux même faire de la smr comme
ça avec le micro au dessus mais c'était
que l'asl smr je déteste ça d'accord tu
essayes de faire un truc tu vas bien
punchy et tout mais que tu étouffes